well as the vaccination process
continues here in southern nevada
concerns are rising for those who
have their second dose pending yeah
today health officials are saying that
99 000 clark county residents are
eligible for their second vaccine dose
christian cossa is joining us live from
our eight news now newsroom with more on
why this and why folks are
not going back to fully complete the
process christian that's right guys well
health officials believe that group of
people
pending their second dose have not
returned because of fears from a bad
experience with the first
shot now today local state health
officials said
thousands 99 000 clark county residents
are eligible for their second dose of
pfizer or modern vaccine
they want to remind the community that
you need both shots to have a maximum
protection
against the coronavirus that 99 thousand
figure also includes people
three to four weeks past their due dates
health officials believe lack of
transportation to vaccination clinics
may be one of several reasons for those
pending appointments many
have different reasons why they are not
getting that second dose
we have some data that
may indicate side effects that they
experienced even if they're not really
related to the vaccine but occurred at
the same time
they may be less likely to get the
second dose
well there are some solutions they say
which is making uh
access more flexible there are evening
hours and weekend
opportunities also texas station will be
doing a drive through
on may 11th now one thing that was
mentioned at the beginning of the
vaccine process was
asking people to get both shots at the
same location well
health officials tell us that will not
matter anymore because there is a
surplus of vaccines
at cashmen and at the convention center
christian casadas 8 news now